[Music]
hello i am dennis canike cincolio from
kenya i am a seventh-day adventist
hello amen
someone wants to join the church
but to know the true sabbath before he
joins
he's i believe this should mean he's
taking me to the book of acts chapter 2
verse 46 and chapter 20 verse 7 and
saying that it's okay to rest at any day
even the first day
how can i approach that challenge
you simply point him to the fourth
commandment
remember the sabbath day to keep it holy
six days shall now lay but let me pray
again father as i answer this critical
question on the sabbath give me simple
wisdom i pray in jesus name amen this is
the fourth commandment
remember the sabbath day to keep it holy
six days shalt thou labor and do all thy
work but the seventh day is the sabbath
of the lord
the sabbath is a personal possession of
god we need to understand that not the
first or the third or the fifth yes he
made them but the sabbath is a personal
possession of god it has a relationship
with him to him that the others do not
have as verily as the israelites had a
relationship to god no other nation had
and god says that over and over in the
bible
he god has never changed that
relationship so this friend of my
brother from kenya needs to he needs to
show his friend the sabbath is a
personal possession of god he calls it
my day isaiah 58 verse
13. if thou turn away thy foot from the
sabbath from doing thy pleasure on my
holy day and call the sabbath and the
light the holy of lord honorable the
sabbath of the the holy of the lord
isaiah 15 13 12-13
it's god's day
this lord jesus christ is lord of the
sabbath
it is his
we need to understand tampering with the
sabbath is tampering with someone else's
property the says of this sabbath is
god's special day as that's why god told
pharaoh in exodus 5
if you do not let my firstborn go i will
kill yours
you see israel special to me that's my
first born the egyptians that's your
firstborn the sabbath is god's firstborn
day if i can put it that way it is
special to him it's not just any day
like sunday through friday it is special
and he calls it my day
hello my sabbath
i never read with god said you know the
second day's his day and the third day
says even though he made all of them
we're talking about relationship god has
a relationship with the sabbath he does
not have with the other six days
as he had with israel he did not have
the other nations but he loves the whole
world and so that friend needs to be
shown no no no no no any day does not
work because god did not say any day he
said the seventh and god knows what he
wants
the seventh that's god's day
so in uh revelation 1 verse 10 john said
i was in the spirit on the lord's day
that's the seventh day there's no the
lord's day the seventh day
[Music]
next question
and may god bless that young man in
kenya as he tries to bring his friends
to the truth you know when bringing
people to christ praying sometimes is
more important than the argument we pray
a lot because god is not willing that
anyone should perish pray a lot and keep
the teaching simple
arguments don't convert people the
spirit doesn't
you